now last week we was talking about
kissing smooching and I talked about a
couple things when I was young you know
when I was young and not everybody knew
how to kissing people was it what it
weren't the first way you knew to say
hey to somebody
first if we knew they teach it a
handshake and that's basically saying
hey let me touch it real quickly let me
touch you say okay I'll let you touch me
but just my hand I say okay that's an
agreement that's a handshake and then
they do a hug
they won't I'm gonna trust you enough to
put both your hands around the around
and touch my back really quick while I
touch your back okay and go boom okay
that was good and then it gets to
another level though when your body
starts to get hot when your loins start
to look around you feel me because when
you're a man and you're yelling you can
only look around with your head and your
neck but at a certain age your wiener
says hey I'm about to peek around as
well and that is cold what is it called
uh Herbert E that's almost full
perverted baby that's when you're
getting lit brah that's when you
suddenly lit for some tit dude but what
I'm telling you is this what I'm trying
to say is that we all started practicing
away kiss and I shared about mine last
week and so you guys had some calls that
came in and I want to hear a couple of
those here we go gang hi feel this is
mofo from Idaho what's up mofo what's up
mofo from Idaho and Idaho's a good place
if you want to uh if you want to get
kind of wind burn on your face and
sunburned at the same time and if you
want to look for gold but not find any
but still dress like you look for gold
then Idaho is a beautiful spot a great
place to get sunburned and and go
missing as well a lot of missing people
in Idaho
Lord so I'm the youngest of six so I had
older siblings and we had a Barbie head
that was like a head and shoulders and
neck so you could do her hair and her
makeup like it was like a mannequin head
so when I would get a chance to be alone
with this Barbie how we practice kissing
think we're alone now it doesn't mean to
be anyone oh okay so you kissed that
little baby that baby Barbie
let me hear more on her neck and her
face and everything and hamsa turned me
off a little wha - a got me tricky dude
this shit's gonna bring old Patrick out
the closet you feel imagine let's hear
more I'm gonna back it up a little bit
in a second here he's tell me what
happened again homework the chance to be
alone with this Barbie her highly
practiced kissing on her neck and her
face and everything and it always it
never failed every time I went to do
that one of my siblings would catch me
and be like mo are you keeping the
Barbies net and I'd be so [ __ ]
embarrassed and so that would just go on
and on and also you know the poles in
the basement I used to put on my roller
skate and like swing around the poles
and practice kissing on those and again
somebody would always catch me and be
like what are you kissing the pole
anyway so funny ah yeah okay look
everybody's got away you know that's
interesting you kissing plastic humans
and you kissing poles you know that's
really you could work at the mall I mean
yeah it almost sounded equal work at the
mall um but yeah this is everybody had a
different way you know some people would
do something different man I had this
boy living across the street from us
named Robert and he would put his hand
in the hot water and get it real hot and
he would make that kind of kiss an area
like a little lips with his hand where
you put your curl your fingers in your
thumb across the front
and then he would kind of kiss that when
it was all warm you know everybody had a
little something we would heat up the
oyster you know where every now and then
things got a little bit homosexual with
the key you know if it's young fellas
they kissing on each other's neck a
little but when you're when you're child
anything gay is not gay gay is just
children
you know remember find out - I found two
of my nephew's one time in the bed and
they in there butt naked so what am I
gonna you know they're children
and one of them had a bunch of damn uh
little Hershey's kisses it in there
would he had a whole damn stack couple
them on his belly and stuff something
and someone were melting a little bit
and the chocolate was getting on his
skin but what am I gonna you know that's
nothing that's children all right let's
take another call that came in here see
oh this is cold I used to practice
kissing on an apple I would take a bite
I would take a look like a little like a
little nipple out of the Apple and then
you know it would leave like a little
hole for like you know you put your
tongue in there and boy man that [ __ ]
got me feeling some type of way you know
yet they're getting that fruit up
putting your tongue into that fruit boy
you could have at least had a little bit
you know you could have cut open the
orange Brian curved out in that sucker I
used to do that when I got a little bit
older I'd dig out the middle of an irons
and throw three of my fingers in that
bastard let's hear more and it was kind
of a sweet treat at the same time mmm
so that was kind of how I used to
practice kissing when I was young and I
really liked the podcast man I really
liked your really like your concept and
uh just keep keep doing you baby boy
gang
thanks colt I like that I like a man
named after a weapon as well Colt you
know or maybe who else ninja star
and if you don't think there's probably
a young black woman out there named
ninja star then you're probably wrong
bad bad girl kissing on Apple let's hit
let's take another one that came in how
you practice getting that lip lock and
going gang I feel I'm calling all the
way from Pennsylvania damn from PA and
that's a much country if you want to see
what your grandparents did drive through
PA man you get out there out near uh
what are some of those areas out there
witty I mean you can smell the butter
you could smell the breast milk in there
I mean these women got some breasts on
them too that's the breast belt do you
be driving you hit us to be like what is
that a speed bump on Interstate black
nah man that's just a couple titties
crossing the road out there cuz it's
that kind of place man and they got skin
just so milky my god that milky skin I
mean just make you want to just
something god damn every titty look like
it down every titty looks big and good
out there but there's nothing like a
real milky breast you know a lot of
times they try to push these days they
push these different type of breasts
this and that you know oh here's that
lean titty rock ready what a lean titty
people want the rest the breast is
supposed to be the breast you know you
know I'm when I was growing up we had a
lady that worked at this lady we live in
apartment for a little bit and it was
for apartments in one big building and
we would play football in the backyard
out back and they had this that big area
and we get out there and just be are
just pretend we were heroes you know and
you had different you know yet a whole
in a certain part yet to go around and
they had drainage coming off of
somebody's laundry room so you had to be
careful and if somebody's running their
dryer that hot air was puffing out of
one area so that's where we would do the
intros
beginning of the game we say off
starting quarterback father and your boy
would come running out of that dryer
smoke from the bottle laundry room and
then we've played a game but they had a
lady who did a verbal sex work by us and
she was like a hotline worker back in
the day they used to have if you called
on the phone line you dialed one nine
hundred big titty or something a woman
would answer and she would like yeah
yeah you know this is uh this is Diane
you know this is Diane uh breast or
something like that you know this big
titty what can I do for you and she
would sit there and she would like to
talk oh yeah let me I'm like I'm taking
your pants off right now oh yeah you
know oh I'm choking you right now I'm
you know I'm not spitting in your
bellybutton you know why like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm hiding olives and
yeah you know they'd get real nasty and
stuff but she was doing verbal sex
working every minute she kept the person
on the line she would uh get more money
for the family but one of her windows
share her window is down by the other
end zone where we played football so you
didn't even want to go score down there
sometimes when she was getting real
vulgar you know she's like oh I got
three olives I got three olives in my
ass you know you like oh god I'm making
martinis it in between my you know she'd
be just getting crazy oh yay she'd be
down there yeah give it to me like
what's going on all right let's take
this call that came in right here here
we go hey Theo I'm calling all the way
from Pennsylvania and this regards to
your last podcast stop practicing your
kissing and I used to take a nice juicy
salt
mango just bite a little small mouse
hole in the side of it you start making
out with a mango let me know what you
think
damn boy you sound like a pervert bucco
what do you you sound like do you doing
something what a mango first of all
mango is the straight-up
[ __ ] of produce you got to think that
maybe you'd think when other when
tomatoes see a mango coming daint saying
oh look at its thought over huh you know
you do think about that you don't think
when two peaches they sitting around
they on the swing set
just peach and you know maybe splitting
up a percocet or something and then they
see this [ __ ] mango get out of a taxi
you know they both think and look at is
you over here
I'm telling you bro mango is a straight
slew of the fruit kingdom gang bro thank
you for calling ma'am and get out your
mama's refrigerator but you sound like
you got to stay home with you being like
that homework hasty oh this is old gun
I'm not in the bay area of California I
was just listening what's up old done
thank you for calling brother Oh word
into your podcast and made me think of
how I used to practice kissing I used to
make out with my elbow bit on the inside
of my forearm and I used to kiss it I
used to [ __ ] give it hickeys and
everything dude that was my [ __ ] I think
I did it for like a year everybody knows
he did it for way longer - even though
you just said that but all her brother
and then I don't know why I stopped
doing it but I haven't thought about
that in many years thank you keep up the
good work
I love the positive message you bring
with the humor attached dang bro Thank
You Man thank you very much thanks for
calling man look they
he making me think I have a limited neck
my neck I got a medium medium to lower
than that you can bear if I look for
something I can't look really long
because I got a I got bringing my neck
back to Center
I got a recenter my neck some people got
that neck day over here they over there
they doing laundry they're looking for
this you know I'm saying they owned a
lost-and-found they could they could do
multitask with that [ __ ] big Reacher
with that fifth [ __ ] limb maybe that
neck but my [ __ ] limited time I got that
limited look piece baby so I couldn't I
couldn't really get into the crease in
my heart my elbow very much but I bet I
did try let me try it oh yeah now that's
the second I put my face there I'll
remember I definitely did oh yeah man
damn dude in my do a mile vogue crease
tastes like it remembers me to you boy
then it's this chick is fine as hell
dude and I remember even this dude this
is so perverse I can t believe I'm
telling you this as I got older
sometimes sometimes my underarm which
had to vibe the scent of a woman to it
and I would sometimes put my face right
down in there and like get a couple of
Huff's off my own off that own my own
[ __ ] little reach crevice right there
that armpit and then I would use that
you know I'd fuel myself to pleasure
myself you know antenna and do
masturbation
so damn
almost was trying to said that but you
know what whatever man that's who I am
that's who I am dude because I wanted
that full-body experience because
sometimes one of my underarms one of my
arm always smell a little bit got that
spaghetti kind of that Italian you know
it's something under there I'm running
like a Primavera you feel me but every
now and then one of my arms had a bit
more of a kind of a fertile feminine
kind of you know uh it kind of had - it
kind of had the same tenor the same kind
of uh the same hit that you get the same
hit off of it you would off of a woman's
body and even maybe a vagina even if I'm
being real honest with you and I know
this is grossing another's kind of
graphic man I'm sorry about that I'm not
trying to be discussed and I'm just
trying to be honest with you but but so
I get a couple hits at at and then I
would use that because that would get my
brain all fired up with that hot pouch
you know it would just it fueled that
because I would have that that vit that
uh the scent I had that scent of a woman
right under my on that hooah
you know and so I get a couple hits at
and then use that to power my my my
ability to touch myself but yeah man we
all did something and it's okay that's
nature nothing wrong with you and
there's nothing wrong with me man we got
a couple more that came in and I got to
tell you about this last ad for the
episode when you're selling online
getting your orders out can be a real
pain what's that pain oh that's getting
my orders out how do you keep track of
who gets what what carrier should you
use are you getting the best rates
that's why you need ship station calm
it's the fastest easiest and most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders just a few clicks and you'll be
managing your orders printing out labels
and getting your product out fast to
keep your customers happy ship station
makes it easy
shipstation helps you get orders out
save money on shipping costs and keep
your customers happy no matter what
you're selling on Amazon Etsy eBay your
own website it brings all your orders
into one simple interface no more going
to PayPal and printing out the thing and
taping it to this and then where does
this go and then who do I now I got to
run them all over to the post off you
can put it all together simple interface
take your shipping to the next level it
works with all the major carriers
including USPS FedEx UPS even Amazon
Fulfillment
no wonder ship station is the number one
choice of online sellers and right now
this past weekend listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
offer code Theo
there's absolutely no risk you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info just visit ship
station comm and click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
Theo that ship station comm use code
Theo ship station make ship happen oh
these are good man let's take another
one right here how you got that smooch
how you get that smooch practice cuz
look some guys lucked out some fancy
guys if he was real rich maybe your mom
come downstairs and give you a little
kiss or something to stay heavy with if
you had a stepmom
maybe she sleep over once a month or
something you like damn I don't even
know what that is for he's just a bank
cuz I'm the one me around are seeing
each other now
but before but if that wasn't your case
then you had to learn to kiss somewhere
and if somebody wasn't kissing you you
had to find a way and that's who I am
and I appreciate you being similar let's
go baby I'm calling about the practicing
kissing you're pretty young I think I
was in sixth grade you know you finally
merged laws with life or different
elementary schools you got all these
girls there they need practice I would
take on hot shows
mmm-hmm homeward melted into shallots
then sit down and let the father that
would like a pair like you know your
first director to the bass and you've
turned to a shower but uh you practice
on that boy you know it was smooth a
little bit was calling with shy he said
I might give it a little tongue tennis a
girl the picture on your selection guy
goes right just picture a nice woman but
all right that's all dang bucko that's
one way to do it man and that's how you
wind up selling AHA and that's how you
end up selling bathroom equipment for
the rest of your life man with that kind
of love for the game right there but
yeah I could understand we can see your
reflection in something and then you go
kiss it now if you sucking on the front
end of a ball of a faucet that might be
kind of homoerotic you might be getting
a little bit homoerotic all right there
bro you might meet a man hell you might
end up dating the ten man
you know if somebody in the next room is
watching Wizard of Oz and even through
the television that 10 man sees you
sucking on the end of a frigging
dripping faucet boy yeah boy that mad
metal maniacs and a pop right out of
your screen bruh and he's gonna want his
uh he's gonna want his chrome polish
daddy look stay safe out there man
wherever you are I am saying that and
thank you for sharing thank you for
sharing that that let's take another
call man let's take one more call that
came in here to the hotline I appreciate
you guys being so supportive I'm excited
about going to Maui in two weeks if you
have a friend on the island tell them to
get to get that hitter man grab some
tickets you know see I just need I'm
ready to have a little bit of break man
I feel a lot of stress in my shoulders I
can't it's like like a tangling
in my shoulders in my neck and I think I
might be allergic to coffee too so you
know me dude I got all the problems baby
I'm wearing this Joe Musgrove today too
son got this beautiful hitter right here
Pittsburgh Pirates shed are one of the
best in the game right there gang bro
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one